robert spencer putin has unleashed
thousands of chechen fighters on the
ukraine uh they are radical muslims they
are battle hardened many of them
are called members of the kill squad
they're notorious for being incredibly
brutal and putin says
he has organized them and turned them
loose to get this eradicate the nazi
leadership
in the ukraine
that's a country where their president
is a second generation holocaust
survivor and is jewish does anyone
buy
putin's bizarro excuse me
oh i doubt that
but uh probably in russia he has a
considerable following still although uh
this
uh invasion has turned out so
differently from how he had clearly
planned that even that may be not the
case any longer or for much longer
anyway uh when it comes to this uh
chechen group
this is sort of a quid pro quo on
putin's part uh ramzan khadirov the
chechen strongman
is a putin client and he has more or
less a free hand to institute islamic
rule in chechnya and to
remain in power with the blessing of
moscow so
with that of course comes certain
obligations and that's why he sent a
contingent of jihadis into ukraine